la séance est ouverte
le contredit analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu l'observation il y
en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues heureux du jour
appellent les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance sur retransmises en direct
sur Public Sénat et notre site internet
chacun sera attentif
à une valeur essentielle au Sénat le
respect qu'il s'agisse des uns et des
autres mais aussi le respect du temps de
parole
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Mélanie Vogel pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le président
il avait seulement 13 ans et toute une
vie devant lui pourtant le 7 janvier
dernier Lucas s'est donné la mort
pourquoi en 2023 en France un gamin
homosexuel en arrive-t-il à se suicider
parce que et croyez-moi je sais trop
bien de quoi je parle il arrive qu'un
envisager qu'une vie de moquerie de
rejet d'exclusion et de haine on arrive
plus à envisager de vie du tout c'est
donc avec beaucoup d'émotions et aussi
avec beaucoup de gravité que je voudrais
m'adresser aujourd'hui à toutes celles
et ceux y compris au gouvernement dont
les propos on nourri et nourrissent ces
violences à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont marché avec la manif pour tous qui
ont raconté que nos familles étaient
contre nature que nos droits étaient
égoïstes caprices que respecter les
mineurs trans c'était de l'idéologie
qu'apprendre aux élèves le respect de la
diversité c'est de la propagande que moi
j'étais un problème
je publie des photos avec ma compagne
précisément pour donner à voir à des
adolescents comme Lucas un avenir où ils
peuvent avoir une place et pourquoi pas
un jour être élu de la République à
toutes celles et ceux qui par homophobie
par transphobie et parfois par simple
cynisme électoraliste nous prennent pour
des bouquets mystères si le suicide de
jeûne LGBT vous peine si vous voulez
vraiment que ça s'arrête commencez par
le commencement faites votre examen de
conscience
dites-vous dites-nous que vous vous êtes
trompé que ce drame vous a fait
comprendre quelque chose que nous
n'étions pas une idéologie un argument
de campagne mais des humains Lucas Dina
Luna aurait pu être vos enfants vos
petits-enfants et leur harceleur aussi
les enfants entendent des répètes ce que
les adultes racontent l'école est dans
la société elle est traversée par ses
débats nourrit par CN et pétri par sa
violence aurez-vous pour la famille de
Lucas pour ses amis l'humilité de
changer
pour vous répondre
la parole
est à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
papendaye
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Vogel
quand un enfant met fin à ses jours il
n'y a pas de mots
pour dire l'émotion
le chagrin la douleur
il n'y a pas de mots
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
et donc j'adresse mes pensées les plus
à ses parents à ses proches à ses amis
amis ce drame montre à quel point la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire la
lutte contre l'homophobie parce que
l'homophobie tue oui doit demeurer une
priorité du gouvernement
l'orientation sexuelle est souvent un
point d'appui des auteurs de harcèlement
il en est de même pour d'autres
caractéristiques comme l'apparence
physique
l'origine la condition sociale au-delà
de la généralisation du plan phare sur
laquelle j'aurais peut-être l'occasion
de revenir nous agissons pour changer
les représentations qui alimentent les n
en matière d'homophobie et d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
prévention elle passe en particulier par
l'éducation à la sexualité et c'est pour
cela que dès septembre dernier j'ai pris
des mesures pour rendre effectif ces
enseignements qui admettons-le ne sont
pas correctement assurés aujourd'hui et
j'ai eu l'occasion de mon entretenir
récemment avec les sénatrices billon
Cohen Rossignol et borchio Fontain
enfin sur la lutte contre l'homophobie à
l'école comme je l'ai annoncé hier j'ai
décidé que dans chaque académie devait
être généralisé dans les prochaines
semaines des groupes de sensibilisation
de prévention et d'action contre les
LGBT phobies et je vais suivre cela
personnellement
nous avons encore c'est vrai madame la
sénatrice du chemin à faire le
harcèlement est une question qui
concerne tout le monde de même que
l'homophobie l'éducation nationale est
pleinement engagée en la matière vous
pouvez compter sur moi
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est de notre collègue Joël
guerriot pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les larmes de sirène pourraient
être le titre d'un conte pour enfant
d'une femme d'un prochain jazz bon d'un
film féérique malheureusement il n'en
est rien de cela les larmes de sirène
sont des granulés plastiques à usage
industriel qui à l'instant où je vous
parle Vienne poussé par des vents de
l'Ouest envahir nos côtes et nos plages
de Loire-Atlantique et de Vendée moins
visible qu'une marée noire mais si
nombreuse et si petite qu'il est
impossible de les ramasser toutes et ce
malgré les efforts des associations et
des collectivités territoriales et je
salue ici l'arrivée de cèdre dès ce
matin à Pornic
les larmes de sirène se dégradent avec
le temps en micro-particules dans l'air
et dans l'eau cette pollution est un
véritable désastre pour la biodiversité
cette contamination tue la vie marine
les poissons agurgitent toujours plus de
plastique qui se retrouvent dans notre
alimentation nous ingérons entre 39000
et 52 000 particules de microplastiques
par an c'est un enjeu de santé publique
la loi est des décrets oblige les
entreprises à se doter d'équipements
limitant la fuite de ces granulés et à
mettre en place des mesures de
protection cela n'apparaît plus
suffisant puisque la pollution actuelle
provient du transport maritime cette
atteinte à l'environnement est
inadmissible nous devons agir plus fort
nous devons aucun moyen de retracer
précisément l'origine de cette pollution
les containers perdus en mer ne sont pas
déclarés nous ignorons la provenance des
navires leur destination et bien sûr des
quantités transportées l'organisation
internationale est chargée de prévenir
des pollutions que fait-elle à ce sujet
Quelle suite sera donnée à la plainte
contre X des mers de Pornic Jean-Michel
Brard et des Sables-d'Olonne Yannick
Moreau peuvent-ils compter sur un
soutien d'État quelle mesure seront
prises pour faire respecter la
législation actuelle et la faire évoluer
sur un plan européen
vous répondre la parole est communiste
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur
Christophe Béchu
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur Joël
guerriot
ce terme de l'arme de sirène je ne
l'aime pas beaucoup parce qu'il est
tellement poétique qui pourrait faire
penser à quelque chose de positif est-ce
que vous décrivez c'est un cauchemar un
cauchemar environnemental un cauchemar
parce que ce sont des dizaines de
milliers de tonnes de granulés
plastiques industriels qui s'échouent
sur toutes les plages de l'Europe si on
comptait en bouteille c'est l'équivalent
de 10 milliards de bouteilles plastiques
sauf que si c'était matérialisé cette
manière ce serait autrement plus simple
pour les associations d'intervenir
une fois que c'est dans la nature c'est
très compliqué parce que c'est ingéré
par l'ensemble des écosystèmes et en
particulier vous l'avez dit par les
poissons ça se diffuse partout et donc
il faut agir en amont d'abord c'est ce
que nous avons fait nous pouvons être
collectivement fiers d'être le pays au
monde le plus ambitieux en matière de
lutte contre ces granulés plastiques
industriels puisque depuis le 1er
janvier 2022 dans le cadre de la loi
Haget il y a une obligation pour tous
les sites industriels qui utilisent ces
granulés de mettre en place des
dispositifs de séparation à la fois pour
les collecter si il s'échappent mais
même des systèmes de grille des systèmes
de séparateur et cette obligation elle
vaut pour les sites pour les plateformes
logistiques pour les ports fluviaux et
pour les ports maritimes mais elle ne
vaut qu'en France et le sujet que vous
décrivez est l'origine probable de ce
qui suit à l'heure actuelle nos côtes
c'est international on a donc un effort
en particulier avec l'Organisation
maritime internationale qui est très
claire et on a de ce point de vue une
chance le président de la République la
redit hier nous allons accueillir au
printemps une session de négociation du
traité international d'élimination des
plastiques ça doit être l'occasion pour
nous de pousser sur ce sujet quant à la
plainte non seulement bien entendu nous
soutenons les maires qui portent plein
de contristes dans ce contexte compte
tenu des dégâts mais j'expertise la
possibilité que le ministère de son côté
puisse se joindre à cette plainte
puisque très concrètement nous sommes
évidemment solidaires en nous retrouvant
tous embarquer avec la même ambition
préserver la biodiversité et faire en
sorte que la transition écologique soit
concrète soit pas seulement des slogans
merci de votre interpellation sur ce
sujet
de donner la parole à notre collègue
Gérard Longuet
pour le groupe les républicains
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Premier ministre monsieur mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
le 10 janvier dernier madame la Première
ministre vous avez présenté votre enfin
votre projet de réforme des retraites en
vous fixant comme objectif de sauver les
retraites par répartition et vous avez
raison ce débat ne pouvait pas être
reporté il était irresponsable de ne pas
débattre de ce sujet et nous avons
l'intention de le faire c'est invité
dans ce débat
dès maintenant un acteur qui avait été
négligé c'est le déclin démographique de
notre pays
820 000 naissances en 2012 il y a 10 ans
720 000 en 2022 une diminution de cent
mille en disant et toutes les années
nous aurons ces enfants en moins il est
vraisemblable et là que le mouvement se
prolonge nous avons pourtant en effet le
meilleur taux de fécondité d'Europe mais
il n'assure pas le renouvellement et il
a perdu 10% en disant nous avons un taux
un désir d'enfant chez les femmes et
chez les hommes d'ailleurs qui qui
restent élevés mais
53% des maires nous déclarent selon une
étude de lunaf qu'il y a qu'elles
auraient aimé avoir plus d'enfants ma
question est très simple madame la
Première ministre
allez-vous vous résigner à ce naufrage
qui comprennent
définitivement le régime par répartition
il me reste un peu de temps là
pour vous répondre du travail du plein
d'emploi de l'insertion
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le ministre Longuet vous avez
débuté votre question en disant
finalement dans le débat sur la réforme
des retraites il y a deux éléments en
première élément d'urgence nous
partageons nous sommes convaincus comme
vous que un déficit de 12 milliards et
demi d'euros par an dès 2027 de presque
15 milliards en 2030 de 25 milliards en
2040 un pic la nécessité de rééquilibrer
le système nous sommes aussi convaincus
ça sera l'objet de nos débats qu'en même
temps que nous équilibrons le système
nous devons l'améliorer apporter des
droits apporter des réponses aussi un
certain nombre d'assurer qui connaissent
des carrières différentes de celles que
nous connaissions précédemment et qu'il
faut mieux protéger vous avez dit et
souligner un second point le fait que le
débat démographique s'invitait dans le
débat sur les retraites vous que la
situation démographique vous avez
qualifié cela de déclin s'inviter dans
le débat sur les retraites je crois en
réalité que cette question démographique
s'invite depuis longtemps dans le débat
sur les retraites et la principale
explication au déficit que nous
connaissons dans les prochaines années
si nous ne faisons rien et justement une
explication démographique vous le savez
comme moi dans les années nous avions
trois cotisants pour un retraité et
c'est le propre d'un système de
répartition et de solidarité
intergénérationnelle ce chiffre a des
cru et aujourd'hui nous avons 1,7
cotisants par retraité et à horizon 2050
devrions nous pourrions être autour de
1,2 c'est l'explication des mesures que
nous prenons et des mesures de
rééquilibrage c'est aussi l'explication
de mesure que nous avons introduit dans
le projet de loi tel qu'il sera examiné
par le Conseil des ministres ensuite par
le Parlement nous allons par exemple
proposer non seulement de maintenir la
possibilité de valider des trimestres du
fait de la maternité de la parentalité
mais aussi d'intégrer de prendre en
compte des trimestres particuliers au
titre cotisé au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents au foyer
tant dans les éligibilité au minimum de
pension que dans l'éligibilité en
fonction de la durée de cotisation au
dispositif de départ anticipé pour
carrière longue nous y voyons là des
freins qui sont levés pour permettre de
concilier une vie familiale la
parentalité avec l'accès dans de bonnes
conditions à la retraite nous savons et
nous avons demandé nous allons demander
pardon avec un chef du gouvernement au
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
de travailler sur l'harmonisation de la
modernisation des droits familiaux et je
ne doute pas des contributions
parlementaires nous aurons aussi à
parler démographique plus largement vous
comprendrez qu'à ce stade de ma réponse
cela dépasse mon seul périmètre
que
[Applaudissements]
je vous suggère une autre voix
complémentaire l'amour de la famille la
famille qui transmet la langue qui
transmet la culture qui transmet les
valeurs qui transmet les réflexes et les
comportements l'amour tout simplement
qui est de la famille qui transmet la
vie
la parole est à notre collègue François
Bonnot pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est le président monsieur le
ministre des Armées chers collègues
depuis 11 mois l'Ukraine subit une crise
dévastatrice
ce week-end encore l'Union européenne
dénoncée un crime de guerre à la suite
d'une frappe contre un immeuble qui a
fait au moins 40 morts
nous avons également une pensée face au
drame qui a coûté la vie ce matin au
ministre de l'Intérieur ukrainien
face à l'intensité du déploiement
militaire russe l'Ukraine est
insuffisamment doté en équipement
vis-à-vis de son agresseur
l'Angleterre annonce la livraison de 14
chars lourds challenger 2 et de 30
aubusier et l'armée ukrainienne d'autres
pays européens doivent procéder à la
livraison de blindés lourds la Pologne
attend le feu vert allemand pour faire
de même la France conforte son aide
militaire en livrant prochainement à
l'Ukraine des chars de combat légers à
mx-10rc
nous ne pouvons que saluer cette
prochaine livraison cependant compte
tenu de la gravité de la situation et du
nombre du crayon qui perd de la vie
chaque jour la France est l'ensemble des
pays européens ne peuvent différer plus
longtemps la livraison des matériels
blindés encore plus performant qui
servent aujourd'hui à l'entraînement de
nos armées et que l'Ukraine réclame avec
insistance
la livraison de charlour domicile et
danseur solaire permettrait aux forces
ukrainiennes de protéger davantage des
civils et d'être équipé d'un matériel de
qualité reconnue quand bien même la
disponibilité ne serait pas immédiate et
nécessitera une formation à une
logistique spécifique nous devons de
répondre à une demande légitime de
l'Ukraine afin de résister aux
innombrables attaques de l'ogre russe
qui cherche par tous les moyens la
destruction et l'asservissement de son
voisin slave monsieur le ministre
allez-vous compléter la livraison des
chars amx10rc de chartiple clair et de
nouveaux systèmes anti-missiles pour
vous répondre la parole est communiste
désormais monsieur Sébastien Lecornu
vous avez la parole si monsieur le
Président du Sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Bono
permettez-moi à mon tour au nom du
gouvernement de m'associer de nous
associer à votre message de condoléances
à l'égard du peuple ukrainien et du
gouvernement ukrainien suite au terrible
drame qui a eu lieu ce matin qui a
coûtait la vie au ministre de
l'Intérieur peut-être rappelé monsieur
le sénateur les trois critères que nous
examinons et que nous retenons à chaque
fois que nous faisons une session
d'armes pour l'Ukraine me rappeler en
quelque sorte notre doctrine le premier
critère il est connu du Sénat c'est
évidemment la logique défensive dans la
maîtrise de l'escalade mais évidemment
ce critère est entendu deuxième critère
évidemment il est contrôlé régulièrement
par la commission des affaires
étrangères et des forces armées du Sénat
c'est évidemment de ne pas détériorer
notre modèle de sécurité et de défense
soit d'ailleurs parce que les délais de
recomplètement seraient trop lents
soi-même tout simplement puisque la
nature même de ce qui serait donnée
pourrait abîmer notre système de défense
puis le troisième critère et non des
moindres il va être délicat dans les
mois et semaines qui vont venir c'est
évidemment le maintien en condition
opérationnelle de ce qui a déjà été
donné à l'Ukraine c'est un enjeu de
taille pour les canons César dont vous
savez que sur les 18 un des canons et
malheureusement désormais complètement
hors d'usage et la question des chars
Leclerc est une question
particulièrement sensible et centrale
cette question du maintien en conditions
opérationnelles sur la doctrine que le
Président de la République nous a
demandé au gouvernement de retenir c'est
de d'avoir une solution rapide d'où la
mx-10 qui constitue une réponse qui est
saluée évidemment par les ukrainiens et
pour les Charles Leclerc le président de
la République nous a demandé au chef
d'état-major des armées à moi-même
d'instruire cette demande moyennant tout
de même l'analyse des trois critères que
je viens de vous indiquer d'autres
sessions peuvent être envisagées dans
les temps qui viennent on parle beaucoup
des chars ce mois-ci au mois de décembre
nous parlions beaucoup de la défense
seul r je rappelle que sur le segment de
défense solaire nous avons des choses à
proposer à l'Ukraine dans les semaines
qui viendront notamment sur les couches
les plus élevées de défense du
territoire ukrainien je remercie
Monsieur sénateur
vous avez quelques secondes
oui merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
réponses
l'Ukraine doit gagner cette guerre et il
en va de l'avenir du monde libre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est abordable la Présidente il
y a de ceci pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
madame la Première ministre vous
qualifiez votre projet de réforme des
retraites de juste solidaire et pérenne
la réalité n'est pourtant pas celle-ci
pourquoi votre projet est injuste
puisque vous allongez la durée de
cotisation à 43 sanitaires pardon et
l'âge de départ en retraite à 64 ans ce
sont principalement les ouvriers les
employés et les femmes qui seront
pénalisés votre projet est un juste
puisque les salariés les mieux rémunérés
vont davantage capitaliser pour leur
retraite tandis que la grande majorité
des travailleurs ne pourront pas
bénéficier du minimum de pensées de
pension à 1200 euros brut votre projet
est injuste car vous allez appauvrir les
seniors qui seront plus longtemps au
chômage et que vous avez précarisé à
l'extrême votre projet ne sera pas
pérenne car vous ne changez pas de
logiciel du financement d'autres
solutions existent pourtant il suffirait
ce n'est qu'un exemple de taxer de 2% la
fortune des milliardaires
vous avez versé 160 milliards d'euros
d'entreprises en contrepartie pendant la
crise de la covid CE quoi qu'il en coûte
ne peut-il être décidé pour garantir une
vraie retraite en bonne santé une
retraite sereine c'est un choix de
société qui est à faire un monde de
juste répartition des richesses pour
l'intérêt général ou celui d'un CAC 40
gorgé de dividendes madame la Première
ministre vous avez choisi alors qu'il
n'y a pas d'urgence extrême d'utiliser
une loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour restreindre
les débats parlementaires à 20 jours à
l'Assemblée nationale et 15 au Sénat
c'est un super 49,3 que vous avez
dégainé des voies s'élèvent pour
souligner l'inconstitutionnalité de
votre démarche madame la Première
ministre c'est parce que cette réforme
voulue par Macron est injuste quelle
frappe est plus faible qu'elle est
rejetée très massivement avec l'ensemble
des syndicats la société tout entière
est vend debout et seule le Medef et
Monsieur Ciotti vous soutiennent encore
madame la Première ministre nous
relayons ici le vaste mouvement qui
s'enclenche et de demain le 19 janvier
nous serons dans la rue avec le peuple
qui exige le retrait de votre projet
pour
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre Madame Élisabeth borde si
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente assassin
comme vous je suis fermement attaché à
notre système de retraite par
répartition comme vous je considère que
c'est l'un des piliers de notre modèle
social et comme vous j'en suis sûr je
veux que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui est
une retraite demain mais madame la
Présidente assassie nous sommes
confrontés à des faits le nombre de
d'actifs baisse par rapport au nombre de
retraités ça n'est pas une opinion c'est
un constat et si nous ne faisions rien
cela conduirait inévitablement à creuser
les déficits et donc à baisser les
pensions ou à augmenter les impôts voir
à remettre en cause notre système de
retraite par répartition et cela avec le
président de la République nous n'en
voulons pas
c'est pourquoi j'ai présenté la semaine
dernière notre projet pour l'avenir de
nos retraites alors c'est un projet
d'équilibre d'abord en demandant aux
Français qui le peuvent de travailler
progressivement plus longtemps et je
mesure ce que cela représente et je
mesure ce que c'est la représente pour
beaucoup et je rappelle madame la
Présidente que les 43 annuités de
cotisation c'est la réforme Touraine
votée en 2014 que nous n'avons pas prévu
nous n'avons pas prévu
d'aller au-delà de ces 43 annuités de
cotisation mais c'est la condition pour
préserver notre système de retraite par
répartition mais au-delà de l'équilibre
dans la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
avec les groupes politiques nous avons
construit un projet de justice et de
progress social un projet de justice
d'abord nous allons améliorer le
dispositif dit carrière longue celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
pourront bénéficier de départ anticipé
de 2 à 6 ans avant l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite nous reconnaissons mieux
la difficulté de certains métiers en
prenant en compte de nouveaux facteurs
d'usure professionnelle en favorisant
les départs anticipés pour raison de
santé en prenant le tournant de la
prévention
et on facilitant les reconversions et
les personnes en invalidité en
incapacité ou en inaptitude pourront
bénéficier d'un départ à taux plein à 62
ans au total 4 français sur 10 souvent
les plus modestes les plus fragiles
celles et ceux qui ont des métiers
difficiles pourront partir avant 64 ans
et ce sont les 20% de travailleurs les
plus modestes qui auront le moins à
décaler lors des parts à la retraite et
notre projet madame la Présidente c'est
aussi un projet de progrès social nous
allons augmenter la pension minimale à
85% du SMIC net pour ceux qui ont une
carrière complète au niveau du SMIC
c'est-à-dire une hausse de 100 euros par
mois et dès cette année ce sont près de
2 millions de personnes futur et actuels
retraités qui bénéficieront d'une hausse
c'est une véritable avancée sociale
madame la Présidente assassy nous avons
la respons d'assurer l'avenir de notre
système de retraite par répartition
parce que c'est lui qui protège les plus
modestes et c'est grâce à lui que nous
assurons par la solidarité nationale une
retraite digne à toutes celles et ceux
qui ont travaillé toute leur vie je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Frédéric
marchand pour groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
je souhaite vous parler aujourd'hui de
zyback je veux rassurer mes collègues je
ne vais pas parler ici d'un talent
émergent de la scène musicale rap mais
plutôt du développement des zones
industrielles bas carbone ce programme
qui vise à accompagner les territoires
industriels dans leur transformation
écologique et énergétique pour gagner en
compétitivité en attractivité
lundi a été dévoilé ont été dévoilés les
deux premières zones industrielles bas
carbone sélectionnées dans le cadre du
plan d'investissement France 2030 il
s'agit des zones industrielles et
portuaires de Dunkerque et de
Fos-sur-Mer qui représente elle seule
près de la moitié des émissions
industrielles de CO2 en France elle
recevront 17 millions d'euros pour
concevoir de nouveaux modes de
production et de captation du CO2 je
veux saluer cette politique qui vise à
créer une synergie entre notre
engagement pour le climat par une
réduction des émissions nettes de gaz à
effet de serre d'au moins 55% d'ici à
2030 et la réindustrialisation de votre
territoire pour assurer notre
souveraineté énergétique favoriser
l'emploi l'innovation la formation et
confirmée notre attractivité pour le
Dunkerquois c'est une incroyable
opportunité ce territoire que l'on
considérait il y a encore quelques
années comme relégué économiquement
marqués à jamais par les conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
portuaire et silurgique et qui est
aujourd'hui un modèle inspirant en
matière de transition écologique
énergétique et économique grâce à cette
nouvelle ambition industrielle sont
créées des laboratoires scrutés enviés
par leur dynamisme l'espoir et la fierté
sont de retour et se sont près de 16000
emplois qui sont attendus sur le
littoral dunkerquois dans les 10 années
à venir permettait au nordiste que je
suis d'en être plus que satisfait ce
travail écolossal exaltant le bassin en
question représentant 21% des émissions
industrielles de CO2 est déjà le site
d'ArcelorMittal a mis en place un
processus de recyclage de l'acier
représentant ainsi une baisse d'un
million de tonnes de CO2 annuel alors
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
préciser davantage les actions initiées
dans ce cadre sur les sites retenus et
leur lien avec le projet les lois pour
l'industrie verte à venir je vous
remercie
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire merci et monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs Center
monsieur le sénateur marchand nous avons
un immense défi économique pour le 21e
siècle
c'est le défi de l'industrie verte la
décarbonation industrielle qui doit être
l'occasion historique pour la France
d'inverser la tendance de 30 années de
délocalisation industrielle pour
relancer l'industrie dans notre pays sur
une base des carbonées c'est une chance
historique et le gouvernement tous les
élus de la République et je salue votre
engagement dans le Nord dans ce sens là
les associations doivent se mobiliser
collectivement pour relever ce défi qui
est aussi une bataille face à la Chine
face aux États-Unis d'Amérique et elle
infection reduxction Act monsieur Biden
les zones à faible émission carbone ces
zones industrielles nous en avons avec
Roland Lescure annoncé deux l'une dans
le Nord chez vous l'autre info sur mer
nous en annoncerons une dizaine de
nouvelles d'ici quelques semaines sur la
base de l'appel à projet qui était lancé
fin 2022 ça doit se compléter de deux
autres actions stratégiques que nous
menons sur l'autorité de le Premier
ministre du président de la République
la première c'est d'avoir une énergie
décarbonée au prix le plus faible
possible c'est ce qui justifie la
relance de l'énergie nucléaire et du
secteur nucléaire en France parce que
cette un des atouts absolument
stratégiques pour gagner cette bataille
de l'industrie verte le deuxième pilier
c'est ce projet de loi sur l'industrie
verte que j'ai proposé à la première
ministre et au président de la
République qui vise à améliorer les
soutiens financiers je pense que les
subventions ne sont pas suffisantes il
faut aussi réfléchir les crédits
d'impôts qui donnent de la visibilité de
la stabilité à notre production
industrielle il faut que nous
travaillons avec civils retaillaux et
Papen DIY à la relance des
qualifications des formations et à la
valorisation des métiers industriels
nous voulons aussi voir comment est-ce
que nous pouvons réserver nos
subventions et nos soutiens financiers à
des productions qui sont réalisées en
Europe et qui viennent pas de Chine ou
d'ailleurs et nous voulons faire de ce
projet de loi pour l'industrie verte
l'un des moteurs avec les zones nous
avaient parlé de cette industrialisation
qui permettra à la France de retrouver
son rang de grande puissance
industrielles
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Claude Tissot pour le groupe
socialiste écologique et républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a près
de 2 ans j'interrogeais déjà madame
barbara Pompili sur l'explosion des
factures énergétiques qui impactaient
déjà fortement nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui la crise énergétique est
encore plus alarmante et difficilement
supportable pour les particuliers des
collectivités les agriculteurs et les
entreprises alors que l'objectif initial
du marché européen de l'énergie était de
faire baisser les prix le constat est
une nouvelle fois le même le libéralisme
à outrance ne tient pas ses promesses en
2021 les tarifs de l'électricité avaient
déjà augmenté de 60% depuis l'ouverture
du marché en 2007 preuve en est que le
conflit en Ukraine n'est pas la seule
explication pourtant face à cette crise
les textes nationaux et européens
passent les uns après les autres mais ne
sont que des rustines d'argent public
qui financent allègrement les
fournisseurs alternatifs et ne
permettent pas de mettre un terme aux
dysfonctionnements et Hermant du marché
d'énergie monsieur le ministre des
solutions sont pourtant proposées ici
sur l'ensemble des bancs de la chambre
haute elles doivent être enfin écoutées
alors qu'une proposition législative
pour réformer le marché d'énergie sera
présenté par la Commission européenne
dans mois à venir la France doit prendre
toute sa part dans ces négociations et
éviter aucun sujet la décorrélation
entre le prix du gaz et ceux de
l'électricité le maintien de l'ensemble
des tarifs réglementés de vente et de
leur rétablissement pour les
collectivités les hôpitaux les petites
entreprises les petites et moyennes
entreprises des exploitations agricoles
ainsi que la préservation des
concessions hydrauliques en dehors des
logiques du marché doivent être des
priorités dans ces négociations comme
l'ont fait l'Espagne et le Portugal avec
une baisse de factures d'électricité de
10 à 20% la France doit également
demander une dérogation temporaire pour
fixer le prix de l'électricité en
fonction de notre propre mix énergétique
dans ce sens reprendre la main sur un
tel marché nécessite d'avoir un
opérateur historique avec deux réelles
capacités d'investissement et
pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre et je vous ai déjà posé la
question il y a quelques mois de ça
pouvez-vous nous dire
pouvez-vous nous éclaircir sur les
projets que vous avez pour le groupe EDF
monsieur le ministre il est temps de
considérer l'électricité comme un bien
commun qui ne peut plus subir les
logiques d'un marché devient fou quelle
position très clairement et quelle
proposition tiendra la France dans les
négociations européennes à venir je vous
remercie
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances c'est de la souveraineté
industrielle Monsieur le Maire
oui monsieur le sénateur nous sommes
d'accord avec tous vos propos
ça vous surprendra mais je suis d'accord
Agnès panier rue naché dirait la même
chose sous le contrôle de la première
ministre est-ce qu'il faut que les
énergéticiens d'abord soient taxés parce
que le bénéficie d'une honte qu'il faut
bien payer le bouclier tarifaire que
nous avons mis en place pour protéger
nos compatriotes contre la flambée des
prix électricité et des prix du gaz et
même chose pour les entreprises oui mais
il règle plus de la moitié de la facture
grâce à la contribution sur la rente
inframmarginale que nous avons mise en
place et qui va rapporter cette année 26
milliards d'euros est-ce qu'ils doivent
contribuer au paiement de ces 280 euros
le mégawattheure en moyenne que nous
avons imposé à la demande du Président
de la République pour les très petites
entreprises pour qu'elle n'ait pas à
payer des factures à 500 600 ou 1000
euros de mégawattheure oui bien sûr et
je recevrai la semaine prochaine des
fournisseurs d'énergie pour les rappeler
alors obligations c'est 280 euros le
mégawattheure et doivent être payés au
moins en partie par les fournisseurs
d'énergie est-ce mon deuxième lieu
réformé le marché européen d’énergie
mais nous avons engagé cette bataille
avec le président de la République
depuis des mois et avec Agnès palier
renaché nous ne passons pas une semaine
voire un jour sans discuter avec ton
partenaire européen pour obtenir
exactement ce que vous souhaitez et qui
est juste que le prix de l'énergie en
France soit payé au coût de production
et pas au coût marginal d'ouverture de
la dernière centrale à gaz cette
solution elle a dominée pendant des
années elle est désormais obsolète nous
voulons que nos compatriotes payent le
prix de l'énergie au coût de production
et pas au coût marginal d'ouverture la
centrale à gaz enfin EDF vous devez vous
réjouir nous avons repris le contrôle de
100% de déesse justement parce que nous
estimons comme vous que l'énergie est un
bien stratégique que l'électricité sera
la grande question économique du 21e
siècle et qu'en prenant le contrôle la
production d'électricité décarbonée en
France nous nous donnons les meilleurs
moyens d'être compétitif et d'avoir une
économie qui réussit
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Christian
Billac
[Applaudissements]
pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
la Défenseur des droits vient de rendre
public ces recommandations suite à son
rapport de 2021 sur les droits des
personnes âgées accueillies en EHPAD les
atteintes graves ou maltraitance envers
les résidents persistent certaines sont
systémiques madame bucléaire est donc
propose plusieurs actions à mener
d'urgence pour résoudre ces situations
inacceptables et restaurer la confiance
des résidents et de leur famille je ne
peux que souscrire à ses prescriptions
et bien modestement
le soutien aux financement des ehpads
publics car ces établissements ne
cherchent pas à faire du profit mais
simplement à rendre un service de
qualité tout en équilibrant leur compte
ces dernières ont créé au cœur de nos
territoires de nos collectivités locales
connaissent une situation financières
dégradée avec une capacité
d'autofinancement négative plusieurs
raisons à cela des taux d'évolution des
tarifs fixés à un fin 2021 avant
l'annonce de la revalorisation du point
d'indice avant l'explosion de
l'inflation sans oublier le
sous-financement des brûles pérennes
comme le complément de traitement
indiciaire les mesures de Ségur ou la
revalorisation de carrière
s'agit de prise en considération de ces
mesures les EHPAD public ne pourront pas
continuer à exercer laissant au seul
secteur privé la responsabilité de
l'accueil des personnes âgées il y a
quelques jours le maire de Frontignan
dans l'Hérault m'annoncer pour sa
commune un déficit prévisionnel de 1 850
pour ces maisons de retraite en 2022
aussi je vous demande monsieur le
ministre si vous souhaitez mettre à jour
le plan de solliathlonage qui date de
2006 en prenant en compte la situation
des EHPAD public je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées monsieur
Jean-Christophe con vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
messieurs le sénateur BIAC vous l'avez
dit l'inflation touche aujourd'hui
durement un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens mais aussi de structures de
notre pays et malheureusement le secteur
du grand âge le secteur de des EHPAD ne
fait pas exception pour autant ce
secteur il peut compter sur un certain
nombre de mesures dont bénéficient
aujourd'hui de mesures de protection
dont bénéficie aujourd'hui l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens c'est pour ça que nous
avons agi de façon résolue nous avons
délégué 440 millions d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires en fin d'année aux ARS
pour soutenir les établissements nous
avons inscrit dans la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 une
augmentation des dotations de soins de
plus de 5% pour soutenir là aussi les
établissements et compenser les
différentes augmentations et notamment
les augmentations auxquelles vous avez
fait référence des pour les
collaborateurs dans les EHPAD c'est pour
ça également que nous avons étendu le
bouclier tarifaire sur l'électricité et
le gaz à l'ensemble de ces
établissements avec un effet rétroactif
au premier juillet 2022 pour autant
l'état poursuit son action on a évité
comme ça un certain nombre de
défaillances de d'établissements qui
étaient en grande difficulté j'ai
demandé moi-même aux ARS d'être
extrêmement vigilants et de pouvoir
soutenir les établissements en
difficulté notamment les établissements
publics avec les départements je
travaille aujourd'hui au quotidien avec
les départements et notamment avec leur
représentants de départements de France
on travaille sur l'augmentation des
tarifs hébergement et dépendances pour
soutenir ces établissements il nous faut
concilier une réalité qui est celle de
du juste financement de ces
établissements dont dépend la qualité de
service et d'accompagnement des
personnes âgées avec l'accessibilité de
l'offre et notamment l'accessibilité de
l'offre à l'aide sociale dans ces
établissements et c'est extrêmement
important assez cause conjoncturelles il
faut aussi s'attaquer à des causes plus
structurelles l'attractivité des métiers
le recours à l'intérim qui a aussi un
coup extrêmement important et des taux
d'occupation qui sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement faibles et c'est à toutes
ces causes qu'on va s'attaquer dans les
mois qui viennent dans le cadre du
Conseil national de la refondation sur
le Bien vieillir et des différentes
mesures législatives que nous prendrons
dans les mois qui viennent
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Martine Berthet pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues
chaque jour nous sommes alertés par nos
élus locaux et par les artisans et
commerçants de nos territoires sur la
flambée des prix de l'énergie boulanger
boucher restaurateur hôtelier acteurs du
tourisme de la montagne tous sont
touchés de plein fouet par cette crise
inédite les tpeme du monde rural sont
confrontés à une hausse de leur charge
d'autant plus aiguë qu'elle supporte
aussi des coups de transport très lourd
la situation dans nos départements
devient très préoccupante dernièrement
dans un communiqué de presse l'Assemblée
des départements de France a formulé
plusieurs demandes elle a appelé à
restaurer l'autonomie que la
décentralisation a conféré au
département pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins de proximité de nos concitoyens
mais également à sortir de la logique de
dérégulation du marché de l'électricité
ces propositions sont légitimes et
bienvenue afin d'éviter les dépôts de
bilan les licenciements la disparition
tout simplement de la vie dans nos
territoires pas par la fermeture des
commerces de à proximité pourtant il ne
s'agit pas seulement comme le fait
l'état d'indemniser les collectivités et
les entreprises avec pour conséquence
d'aggraver le déficit public il est
essentiel de prendre des mesures fortes
comme la décorrélation du prix de
l'électricité de celui du gaz nous
produisons une électricité à prix peu
cher grâce à notre parc nucléaire et à
notre hydroélectricité nous ne pouvons
plus sacrifier notre tissu économique et
social et mettre le pays tout entier en
grave danger pour conserver quoi qu'il
en coûte notre participation à un marché
européen de l'électricité des réguliers
celui-ci s'est retourné contre nous il
nous pénalise fortement dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons aussi
le gouvernement va-t-il enfin entendre
cet appel pour la décorrélation du prix
de notre électricité de celui du gaz je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole de la
ministre de la transition énergétique
Madame Agnès panière une Achille merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Berthet vous m'interrogez sur
la réforme du marché de l'électricité au
fond permettez-moi d'abord de rappeler
parce que je crois que c'est important
que les ménages français et les très
petites entreprises françaises
bénéficient aujourd'hui vous en avez
touché un mot du bouclier énergétique et
du plafonnement de prix l'électricité
qui sont les mesures les plus puissantes
en Europe pour protéger ses ménages et
ses entreprises contre l'augmentation du
prix l'électricité je crois que c'est
important de le souligner et je veux
rappeler ça d'ailleurs été dit à
l'instant par mon collègue Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'économie que ces
dispositifs sont essentiellement
financés par la récupération des profits
réalisés par les fournisseurs
d'électricité qui bénéficient de cette
augmentation des prix n'a rien à voir
avec le coût de revient de leur propre
production ou de leur fournitures donc
ce point est bien traité mais vous avez
raison d'appeler de vos vœux une réforme
en profondeur du marché électrique cité
européen dont je rappelle et cela vient
également d'être dit que nous menons ce
combat depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
Bruno Le Maire barbara Pompili avant moi
et moi-même et je veux vous rassurer oui
nous travaillons donc à une marché à une
réforme du marché qui permettent aux
Français d'avoir un coût d'électricité
qui représente la réalité de la
production électrique française oui la
Commission européenne a partagé à la fin
de l'année 2022 un cadrage de cette
réforme qui va dans le sens des
propositions que nous lui avons faites
oui la Commission européenne a également
indiqué qu'elle présenterait et qu'elle
soumettrait au Conseil européen des
ministres de l'énergie dans le courant
du premier semestre un propre une
proposition de texte qui va dans ce sens
et donc je vais vous rassurer nous
sommes effectivement à la manœuvre pour
obtenir ce bouger qui permettent aux
entreprises qui produisent de
l'électricité dans produire plus sur
notre territoire c'est aussi tout
l'enjeu du projet de loi d'accélération
de production des énergies renouvelables
et d'accélération des procédures
administratives sur le nucléaire que
nous portons car pour payer le juste
prix l'électricité encore faut-il en
produire suffisamment
est trop long il y a urgence venez dans
nos territoires voir les entreprises qui
sont en train de fermer il y a vraiment
urgence à agir
si je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Olivier Jacquin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
avec plaisir merci monsieur le Président
de chers collègues monsieur le ministre
au printemps 2021 je défendais avec le
groupe socialiste une proposition de loi
promouvant la présomption de salariat
pour les travailleurs de plateformes
dérisés que madame la Première ministre
alors ministre du Travail rejeté d'un
revers de main depuis la Commission
européenne avec Nicolas Schmitt a
présenté en décembre 2021 une
proposition de directive reprenant ce
principe et le Parlement européen
adoptera sa position en faveur de ce
texte dans les prochains jours dans le
même temps vous ne parvenez pas et c'est
heureux à convaincre les gouvernements
de venir sur vos positions comme on
atteste l'isolement de la France au sein
du Conseil des Ministres de l'Union
européenne monsieur le ministre alors
que le Président de la République se
fait le chantre de la construction
européenne alors que la majorité des
institutions est de plus en plus de
gouvernement se prononcent en faveur de
la présomption de salariat et donc d'une
véritable avancée sociale à l'échelle
européenne quand allez-vous changer de
position
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail du plein d'emploi et
de la cerceau merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Jacquin
vous avez évoqué la situation des
travailleurs plateformes et la meilleure
façon de reconnaître des droits sociaux
collectifs ces travailleurs plateformes
le droit français est connu vous l'avez
rappelé il a été fixé dans le cadre de
la loi d'orientation sur l'immobilité
qui a donné lieu à deux ordonnances
c'est le même ratifié par le Parlement
en tout cas pour la première qui fige
justement ces principes de
représentation depuis il y a une
initiative de la Commission européenne
qui vise à faire adopter par le
Parlement et par le Conseil une
directive sur le droit des travailleurs
plateformes vous dites la situation de
la France isolée lors du dernier conseil
des ministres du travail dernier conseil
des ministres européen du travail le 8
décembre il n'y a eu aucune majorité ni
pour la directive le projet directive ni
contre la directive et la France que
vous qualifiez d'isoler a défendu une
position qui était défendue par une
grosse douzaine de pays européens vous
conviendrez que lorsque le conseil se
divise en trois tiers ça n'est pas tout
à fait la même définition l'isolement
que je peux avoir que je peux avoir avec
vous nous continuons à discuter la
suédoise a indiqué remettre c'est le
projet directive à l'ordre du jour et
nous estimons que l'issue des travaux
pourrait intervenir à la fin de la
présidente espagnole c'est-à-dire à la
fin du second semestre 2023 nous sommes
convaincus de pouvoir trouver dans le
dialogue une position qui soit
respectueuse de chacune des législations
nationales tout en permettant de
garantir le droit des travailleurs de
plateforme dans l'attente nous
continuons à travailler au niveau
national à la fin du mois d'octobre j'ai
installé les premiers groupes de travail
à la suite des élections visant à
désigner les représentants tant des
plateformes que des salariés que des
travailleurs plateformes c'est le
dialogue et féconds puisque dans
quelques minutes avec Clément bonne
ministre délégio transport nous
rejoindrons les locaux de l'Autorité de
régulation pour assister avec les
représentants des chauffeurs avec les
représentants des plateformes à la
signature du premier accord social en
matière de travail des plateformes et
cet accord porte sur quoi il porte sur
le tarif minimum des courses avec un
accord soutenu par les représentants de
70% des chauffeurs c'est la
démonstration que le cheval que nous
avons fait de respecter le principe
d'indépendance des chauffeur dans la
mesure où le droit permet de le
respecter et où leurs droits à eux sont
respectés ne peut se marier avec l'idée
d'une protection collective cet accord
met la démonstration il en appelle
d'autres et il nous permet aussi de
montrer à nos partenaires européens que
nous pouvons marier l'indépendance
l'entrepreneuriat et la protection des
droits sociaux
Monsieur Jacques
votre réponse monsieur le ministre ne
m'étonne pas elle est toute portée sur
le dialogue social c'est votre doxa qui
finalement consiste à défendre plus les
plateformes que les travailleurs de
plateforme car la réalité c'est quoi
c'est une précarité extrême dans ce
domaine c'est des travailleurs sans
papiers en fait c'est une politique du
SFR qui vise à mener un tiers statut
vous me parlez dialogue social et la
réalité c'est que les élections
professionnelles que vous avez
organisées non connu qu'un très très
faible succès avec seulement quelques
pourcents de participation des
chauffeurs et des livreurs et l'accord
de ce matin peut-être 70% des des
associations et représentants mais
quatre organisations sur sept et les
deux syndicats n'ont pas souhaité le
signer car on évoque pas le revenu
minimum bref réforme des retraites
réforme de l'assurance des chômage ou
ubérisation votre gouvernement et
véritablement celui de la de la
régression sociale en France et en
Europe merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la parole de notre collègue Serge
babary pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues qu'il est
compliqué de simplifier
réclamé par notre collègue Olivier Cadic
depuis un rapport d'avril 2018 de la
délégation aux entreprises la fusion des
1400 guichets des six pôles de
formalités aux entreprises a été
réalisée par la loi pacte du 22 mai 2019
le choix de l'INPI pour gérer ce guichet
unique avait surpris on ne passe pas
facilement de l'enregistrement de 15000
brevets par an à la gestion de 5
millions de formalités concernant les
créations d'entreprise les modifications
et les cessations on simplifie pas en
numérisant sans alléger les procédures
sur l'année 2022 les créateurs et
entrepreneurs ont pu utiliser ce service
marqué par de nombreux
dysfonctionnements et blocages depuis le
1er janvier 2023 le site et la voie
unique obligatoire pour effectuer les
différentes formalités d'entreprises
malheureusement une attaque informatique
l'a rendu inutilisable du 3 au 7 janvier
monsieur le ministre de guichet unique
fonctionnera-t-il correctement et
surtout quand sera-t-il simplifié pour
que nos entrepreneurs produisent plutôt
de la valeur que des renseignements
administratifs
pour vous répondre la parole comme ils
disent de l'Économie des Finances
Monsieur le Maire
qui est le sénateur babary de poser
cette question qui préoccupe je le sais
des milliers d'entrepreneurs est-ce que
l'idée de créer un guichet unique et
nécessaire et bonne vous l'avez porté je
suis convaincu que oui et je sais que
l'immense majorité des entrepreneurs en
sont convaincus ça permet de passer de
six guichets à un seul guichet de 56
formulaires à un seul de 70% de démarche
écrite à des démarches à 100% numérisées
donc c'est un facteur de simplification
majeur est-ce que la situation actuelle
est satisfaisante non non parce que nous
avons été l'objet comme vous l'avez
rappelé d'une attaque cyber avec 120 000
connexions par seconde qu'à saturé le
site il a fallu remettre le site en
l'état cela nous a pris quelques jours
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant encore sur
l'ergonomie même du site il reste des
améliorations à apporter je le reconnais
bien volontiers est-ce que nous faisons
le nécessaire oui nous avons reçu hier
le directeur général de l'Institut
National de la Propriété Industrielle
nous lui avons demander des
améliorations nous lui avons demandé des
corrections nous sommes à l'écoute de
tous ceux qui créent leur entreprise ou
qui modifient des indications sur leur
entreprise pour leur apporter toutes les
réponses qu'ils souhaitent je le redis
nous sommes au service des entrepreneurs
ce site est une amélioration il doit
être corrigé aujourd'hui dans son
fonctionnement ce sera fait dans les
toutes prochaines semaines nous avons
laissé jusqu'au début du mois de mars
pas plus tard pour que le site soit
effectif opérationnel simple et d'accès
direct pour tous les entrepreneurs
monsieur le ministre l'État a été
prévenu très en amont des risques de
dysfonctionnement dès l'automne 2022 des
inquiétudes sur le caractère
opérationnel du guichet unique se sont
multipliés de la part de tous les
professionnels qui accompagnent les
entreprises expert-comptables avocat
notaire etc des remontées alarmantes du
terrain ont incité de nombreux sénateurs
à vous alerter question écrite courrier
et même organisation de deux tables
rondes préconisant une solution de repli
en cas de blocage vous avez reconnu que
le système nécessitait quelques
optimisations en effet mais aussi
certainement une protection efficace
contre les cyberattaques en catastrophe
un arrêté du 28 décembre 2022 a prévu
une procédure de secours de manière à
assurer la continuité de service ce que
font aujourd'hui les réseaux consulaires
ainsi que le retour d'infographie
face au bug de ce lancement raté
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Jean
agréé pour le groupe Union centriste
bien monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale il y a quelques
jours dans les Vosges Lucas 13 ans s'est
donné la mort il est victime de
harcèlement scolaire car homosexuel sa
famille avait pourtant signalé la
situation en septembre dernier l'action
de l'équipe pédagogique du collège n'a
pas suffi une enquête diligentée par le
parquet d'Épinal est en cours et
déterminera les responsabilités de
chacun
de penser vont naturellement aux parents
et à ses proches et permettez-moi d'y
associer particulièrement mon collègue
Daniel grémillier le dernier rapport de
nos collègues Colette mélo et Sabine
avant ce que 10% des élèves pourraient
subir une forme de harcèlement au cours
de leur scolarité soit presque un
million d'enfants un quart de ses
victimes sont je suicide en 2021 22
enfants ont mis fin à leurs jours suite
au harcèlement qu'il subissait à
l'évidence et cela malgré la loi de mars
2022 notre système éducatif ne réagit
pas comme il le faudrait j'avais déjà
interpellé votre prédécesseur au sujet
des messages haineux et violents
présents sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'encontre de collégiens non sa réponse
le ministre avait indiqué l'importance
du programme PHARE avec comme ambition
une école sans harcèlement monsieur le
ministre vous partagez cette ambition
vous venez de le rappeler avec
l'intervention de notre collègue Mélanie
Vogel encore faut-il que les dispositifs
annoncés pour lutter contre l'homophobie
soit efficace
novembre dernier vous avez souligné les
excellents résultats du programme PHARE
permettez-moi d’en douter ce programme
est censé être appliqué dans le collège
de Lucas on peut alors s'interroger sur
les moyens mis en oeuvre pour soutenir
cette ambition tout comme on peut
s'interroger sur le cyber-harcèlement et
sur l'efficacité du pôle national de
lutte contre la haine en ligne monsieur
le ministre que comptez-vous faire
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse c'est pas fan d'ail
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Ingré en effet
Lucas est une victime de plus de
harcèlement scolaire en l'occurrence de
harcèlement homophobe cette situation
comme vous l'indiquez avec été signalé
par les parents et prise en charge à
l'automne par la communauté éducative du
collège Louis Armand de Golbey dans
votre département des Vosges mais à
l'évidence cela n'a pas suffi une
enquête est en cours et nous aurons à en
tirer les leçons la loi Balanant que
vous avez votée monsieur le sénateur a
fait un délit du harcèlement scolaire et
accentuer la prise de conscience de la
gravité du phénomène vous l'avez dit un
élève sur 10 est victime de harcèlement
au cours de sa scolarité avec des
conséquences parfois catastrophiques
en effet nous avons généralisé à la
rentrée le programme phare de prévention
et de lutte contre les phénomènes de
harcèlement ce programme a été en
version expérimentale si je puis dire
dans 6 académies jusqu'à la rentrée
dernière il a donné de bons résultats
dans les académies concernés c'est
pourquoi nous avons décidé de le
généraliser avec la création d'équipes
d'élèves ambassadeurs avec la formation
de personnels référant et nous avons
aussi lancé une grande campagne de
communication à propos des numéros 30 20
et 30 18 c'est d'ailleurs ce que
préconisait les sénatrices mélo et Van
egg dans leur rapport sur le harcèlement
scolaire et sur le cyber-harcèlement
vous avez raison également d'indiquer
que le cyber-harcèlement prolonge en
quelque sorte les situations de
harcèlement scolaire et les plateformes
de réseaux sociaux doivent faire plus en
la matière en dépit de nos pressions il
faut que les choses avancent de ce côté
là l'objectif c'est bien de faire que
les communautés éducatives soient plus
protectrices plus engagée et plus formés
vous pouvez compter de ce point de vue
là sur l'éducation nationale et sur
l'ensemble du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le ministre nous savons que
Madame la madame la Première dame Madame
Brigitte Macron était très engagée elle
disait il y a encore quelques mois tous
les jours je pleure monsieur le ministre
les larmes ne suffisent plus nous
comptons sur vous notre jeunesse compte
sur vous
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Stéphane Le ridullier pour le groupe les
républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Intérieur
depuis des semaines plusieurs quartiers
de Marseille mais aussi d'autres
secteurs d'autres métropoles comme
Nantes sont victimes d'une véritable
conquête de territoire par des
trafiquants de drogue mais aussi le
crime organisé certains de ces habitants
des quartiers cités ce sont même
mobilisés pour essayer d'empêcher
l'installation du trafic et également
protéger leur famille en se relayant
jour et nuit
alors comment en sommes-nous arrivés là
Monsieur le Ministre comment des
quartiers autrefois tranquilles se sont
transformés en moins d'une génération en
Chicago sur Rhône ou Bronx sur Loire
quand des citoyens on viennent à voir ce
protéger par eux-mêmes c'est le début
d'une lente déconstruction du processus
de civilisation
l'état recule les lois de la République
s'effacent et la loi du plus fort
s'impose à tous ce que subissent ces
habitants de ce ministre c'est à la fois
les conséquences de l'explosion de la
délinquance des mineurs l'effondrement
de la chaîne pénale la surpopulation
carcérale et également la banalisation
de la drogue la drogue justement voilà
le cœur du problème et seul la fermeté
la guerre contre ce fléau sans relâche
pourra régler définitivement ce problème
alors monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur êtes-vous prêt véritablement
cette guerre
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
ce que Gérald Darmanin
monsieur le Président du Sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le rodulier je peux être
d'accord avec une partie de votre
intervention et je sais que le ministre
de la Justice proposera sous l'autorité
de la première ministre dans quelques
semaines un texte de loi qui répondra me
semble-t-il aux questions que vous
évoquez sur la chaîne pénale ou sur
l'action de nos tribunaux permettez-moi
de revenir peut-être plus concrètement
sur l'action du ministère de l'Intérieur
notamment dans votre département vous
avez raison il y a depuis vous allez
citer vous-même une génération une
banalisation de la drogue et des
trafiquants quel que soit cette
trafiquants vous parlez des mineurs mais
il ne s'agit pas vous le savez bien que
du mineur qui se nourrissent du trafic
de drogue et qui ont multiplié les
points deal et que multiplié évidemment
l'argent sale l'argent facile qui vient
de la drogue mettant en coupe réglé un
certain nombre de quartiers je ne peux
cependant pas vous laisser dire monsieur
de sénateur que l'État baisse ses bras
ou l'autorité d'État n'est pas au
rendez-vous ou que cette guerre n'est
pas menée je voudrais donner un exemple
très concret dans notre département mais
je sais que vous le savez en lien avec
la préfète de police
90% de trafiquants en plus arrêté en un
an le doublement des saisies de tonnes
de cannabis dans votre département
passant de 2,8 tonnes à 5,7 tonnes 300
policiers gendarmes supplémentaires en
un an et demi dans la ville de Marseille
et 222 points de Deal ce qui est
beaucoup qui sont passés à 180 - 42
points de Deal mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
encore 180 points de Deal c'est à dire
énormément encore de trafic dont dans ce
quartier où je voudrais dire qu'en une
semaine non seulement la mobilisation
des habitants vous avez raison a été
forte mais également celle de la police
celle de gendarmerie désormais une
section de CRS et continuellement dans
ce quartier 10 interpellations au lieu
et ce produit ne sait pas installer dans
ce quartier je voudrais dire salut votre
engagement suite à député également
roubache ce qui manque aussi monsieur le
sénateur vous le savez bien c'est les
caméras de vidéoprotection à Marseille
et nous avons et vous inciter des villes
qui ne connaissent pas forcément de
nombreuses caméras de vidéos protection
nous payons désormais 80% 80% des
financements des caméras de
vidéoprotection à Marseille puis merde
Marseille s'est engagé j'espère que tous
ensemble convaincra également d'aller
encore plus loin parce que 50 par an ce
n'est pas encore assez
monsieur de rue duvier
oui monsieur le ministre sur ce combat
je ne doute pas de la sincérité de votre
engagement mais je pense clairement
qu'il faut aller plus loin et aller
beaucoup plus loin c'est construire des
prisons pour rétablir la chaîne pénale
allez beaucoup plus loin c'est condamné
et incarcéré systématiquement les prix
modalinquance sur le chemin de la multi
récidive allait beaucoup plus loin c'est
en finir également avec l'excuse de
minorité et aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est aussi avant tout enlever de
l'esprit de certains consommateurs
qu'acheter une barrette de cannabis
c'est comme acheter un tube de doliprane
la parole est à notre collègue
victoire jasmin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame depuis la présentation de votre
projet de loi relative à la réforme des
retraites la colère gronde partout en
France les Français sont très inquiets
et vous avez décidé d'ignorer les
partenaires sociaux votre projet n'est
pas indispensable pour le moment il
entraînera un recul social sans
précédent 70% des Français la refusent
ils sont contre cette réforme elle est
injuste et injustifiée vous avez fait le
choix du milieu les syndicats l'absence
de concertation de dialogue social
s'apprendent à un mépris volontaire
demain le pays s'arrêtera compte tenu du
front syndical uni qui appelle à la
mobilisation contre votre projet après
la crise sanitaire la France a besoin de
sérénité vous avez fait le choix de la
double peine d'une part l'allongement
brutale de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite au compte de la pénibilité des
carrières perturbées et des parcours
compliqués particulièrement la situation
des femmes qui paieront un lourd tribu
mais aussi celles qui sont victimes des
situations particulièrement difficiles
et des situations modestes madame la
ministre pourquoi refusez-vous le
dialogue social pourquoi choisissez-vous
le chaos partout en France pour toi
voulez-vous remettre au travail les plus
pauvres les plus fragiles et
particulièrement les femmes je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole de
kabyliste du travail nous plaît d'emploi
de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du somme
merci à Monsieur le Président Madame
triste jasmin je dois avouer être un peu
perplexe à écouter votre question
perplexe parce que cette question des
retraites d'abord nous en débattons
collectivement je crois depuis 4 ou 5
ans et surtout depuis maintenant 4 mois
avec madame la Première ministre nous
avons ouvert des concertations et ces
concertations toutes les organisations
patronales y ont participé mais aussi
toutes les organisations syndicales
absolument toutes toutes celles qui
siègent au Conseil d'orientation des
retraites ce sont des dizaines de
réunions ce sont des dizaines d'heures
discussions c'est un projet de loi que
nous avons présenté avec la chef du
gouvernement qui sur bien des aspects a
été amélioré par cette concertation
améliorer sur la prise en compte de la
pénibilité pour faire en sorte que les
métiers les plus exposés à l'usure
professionnelle soit mieux protégée et
c'est un milliard d'euros nous allons
consacrer à la prévention de la
pénibilité tout en renforçant le suivi
médical améliorer sur la prise en compte
des carrières longues en tenant compte
tout particulièrement de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 18 ans qui
n'étaient jusqu'à présent pas plus
protégé que ceux qui commençait avant 20
ans pour permettre un départ anticipé là
aussi à 60 ans et cela concerne tout
particulièrement les apprentis améliorer
sur la question de l'emploi des seniors
améliorer encore sur la question de la
retraite minimale avec une indexation de
celle-ci pour tenir cette promesse que
de la République c'est long trompette de
mieux protéger ses aînés mais aussi pour
revaloriser la pension des retraités
actuels qui ont les plus petits revenus
après une carrière complète améliorer
sur les retraites agricoles améliorer
sur la prise en compte des trimestres
obtenus au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents au foyer
tant pour les éligibilité au minimum de
retraite que les éligibilité à des
départs anticipés pour carrière longue
ce sont les concertations qui ont permis
cela madame la sénatrice et je sais nous
savons que demain il y aura une
mobilisation et je sais que parmi les
manifestants beaucoup sont de bonne foi
beaucoup souhaitent faire entendre une
opinion que nous devons écouter que nous
devons entendre ce acquis je voudrais
qu'un reproche à formuler c'est ceux qui
diffusent des fake news des fausses
informations qui font peur qui disent et
c'est souvent sur vos bancs qui disent
que les 25% des plus proches seraient
décédés je suis parfois perplexe à
entendre dans les rangs du groupe
socialiste la promesse d'une retraite à
60 ans alors qu'on coûte on sait que ça
coûte 85 milliards d'euros et que même
votre président de groupe qualifié ça
d'accord bricoler sur un coin de table
de réalisme pas tout cela madame la
sénatrice regardez le texte nous
défendons je suis sûr que vous qui avez
voté l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation à 43 ans saurait vous
retrouver dans l'accompagnement que nous
mettons en place
pourquoi vous vous attaquez pas au super
profit pourquoi ce mépris à l'égard de
syndicats parce que vous avez parlé de
concertation mais pourquoi seront-ils
demain dans la rue Unis alors posez-vous
les vraies questions monsieur le
ministre c'est pas parce qu'ils étaient
peut-être à côté de vous que vous les
avez entendu alors faites l'effort qu'il
faut pour que les syndicats les
syndicats sont satisfaits dans leur
demande et que les femmes ne soient pas
les valeurs de rajustement donc Madame
la Ministre madame la Première ministre
vous vous avez depuis un moment commencé
les 49-3 j'espère vraiment que le
dialogue va permettre que les syndicats
et particulièrement les personnes qui
ont déjà beaucoup de pénibilité dans
leur emploi puis satisfaire par les
mesures que vous allez prendre je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le groupe les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre l'agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur le
ministre manger des pommes c'est fini
nous avons bien compris aujourd'hui nos
vergers de pommiers sont en danger nos
pomiculteurs sont à l'agonie hausse des
coups de production principalement dû à
la crise énergétique baisse de rendement
et un prix d'achat par les grossistes et
les grandes surfaces sans cesse revues à
la baisse nous assistons là un véritable
massacre à la tronçonneuse sont pas mémo
sont ceux que j'entends sans arrêt sur
le terrain un chiffre pour illustrer
l'impact économique pour cette filière
le coût du stockage moyen connaît une
hausse de plus de 400%. nos
arboriculteurs ont dû aussi faire face
en 2022 à tant d'aller à climatique gel
épisode de grêle sécheresse historique
ils sont aujourd'hui acculés par la
crise énergétique un autre chiffre si
vous le permettez aujourd'hui la grande
distribution achète à moins de 30
centimes le kilo de pommes alors que le
coût de production est à 45 centimes
mais qu'en toute logique il faut des
vendre nos pommes à 50 centimes le bon
prix ce n'est pas le bas prix le bon
prix c'est le juste prix celui qui va
permettre à nos producteurs de pommes de
vivre tout simplement dignement de leur
métier alors Monsieur le Ministre venait
d'annoncer votre plan de souveraineté
pour la filière fruits et légumes ça
serait inconcevable de ne pas réagir
avec responsabilités avec pragmatisme
vis-à-vis de nos producteurs et en
particulier de nos producteurs de pommes
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jean-Baptiste blanche excuse
Marc fenault qui est justement avec des
pomiculteurs mais eux également des
exploitants de poires pour le salon de
l'Association nationale des pommes et
poires à Angers je comprends la
situation que vous décrivez monsieur le
sénateur et nous sommes d'ailleurs à
pied d'oeuvre vous l'avez dit nous
sommes conscients des difficultés nous
les partageons la hausse des coûts de
production les difficultés rencontrées
dans les négociations commerciales le
manque de main d'oeuvre la concurrence
aussi de certains pays comme la Pologne
premier élément l'augmentation de 20
centimes du prix du kilo de pomme dans
les grandes surfaces et demandée par les
producteurs c'est une question
essentielle pour leur trésorerie pour
leur capacité à produire c'est tout
l'enjeu de la loi égalim 2 cette loi
vous le savez ne couvre pas les fruits
et les légumes à l'heure demande
d'ailleurs et c'est un regret il faut
sans doute pouvoir se poser la question
et il travaillait car pour protéger la
rémunération des agriculteurs il nous
faut à la fois des contrats conclus dans
le cadre de cette loi mais également
assumer un discours clair devant les
Français le bon prix ce n'est pas le
prix le plus bas c'est le prix juste
celui qui permet de rémunérer le
producteur le producteur il aime ses
fruits je crois que c'est Félix Leclerc
qui chantait que chaque pomme est une
fleur qui a connu l'amour il ne faut
donc valoriser ses fruits deuxième sujet
des références monsieur le sénateur
deuxième sujet de préoccupation des
producteurs de pommes celui du retrait
des produits phytosanitaires et les
difficultés pour lutter contre les
pucerons c'est un peu moins romantique
où le développement de maladies liées à
des champignons là aussi il faut assumer
un discours clair il faut mener les
transitions en cours et entités celles à
venir il faut le faire avec un double
objectif celui protéger nos cultures et
celui de répondre aux enjeux de santé
publique environnementaux et aux
attentes sociétales produire oui mais
produire mieux et c'est tout le sens de
la planification souhaitait par madame
la Première ministre ce sont des
transitions que nous devons mener à
l'échelle européenne afin qu'elle ne
soit pas pénalisante pour les
producteurs français elle nécessite
d'accompagner la filière en
développement la recherche
d'alternatives afin de ne pas laisser la
filière sans solution technique c'est
l'un des objectifs du plan de
souveraineté fruits et légumes qui est
en train d'être construit avec les
acteurs sous l'égide de mon émis en
collègue le ministre Marc feno je vous
remercie
monsieur blanc
collègue Olivier Cadic pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères elle
fait suite à mon cinquième déplacement
au Liban en arrivant à Beyrouth une
odeur de fioul qui alimente les
générateurs vous prend à la gorge
l'absence d'électricité m'a rappelé mon
arrivée en Ukraine en trois ans la livre
libanaise a perdu 90% de sa valeur
l'inflation sur un an s'élève à
162%. la crise bancaire a ruiné les
Libanais le Liban connaît une
aggravation de la situation économique
et sociale ayant entraîné un exode
massif et sans précédent de la
population active le blocage politique
du Hezbollah qui a privé le Liban d'un
président pendant plus de deux ans
serait reproduit depuis le mois
d'octobre j'ai rencontré de nombreuses
associations et des personnalités
politiques de toute tendance j'ai pu
apprécier le travail des équipes
françaises conduite par notre
remarquable ambassadrice Anne griot que
ce soit dans la santé l'enseignement les
infrastructures le social
tous mes interlocuteurs ont loué
l'action de la France pour aider les
Libanais et je vous le dis madame la
ministre cette reconnaissance m'a
procuré un grand sentiment de fierté
pour la France et notre action
collective il décrit une élite qui
entrave les enquêtes sur des dizaines de
millions de dollars des fonds qui
auraient été détournés de la Banque
centrale blanchie en Europe mais aussi
sur l'explosion du port de Beyrouth qui
a fait plus de 120 tués dont trois de
nos compatriotes plus de 5000 blessés et
80 000 déplacés ces interlocuteurs m'ont
demandé de relayer auprès de vous le
rappelle à tout faire pour que justice
soit rendue un crime impuni est un crime
récompensé m'a lancé un député des juges
européens viennent d'arriver au Liban
dont un juge français quel progrès
pouvons-nous attendre de leur
déplacement au Liban je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe des
Affaires étrangères Madame Catherine
Colonna merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Cadic merci de
votre intérêt pour le Liban un pays cher
la France et vous vous êtes rendu il y a
quelques jours encore en mission au
Liban la France n'a qu'un but monsieur
sénateur le bien-être du peuple libanais
nous l'appuyons sur les plans
humanitaires économiques avec l'année
passée encore 100 millions d'euros nous
l'appuyons sur le plan politique comme
je l'ai fait en octobre dernier comme
vous l'avez fait récemment et je redis
aujourd'hui que les responsables
libanais doivent dépasser le blocage
actuel et que le Liban doit se doter
d'un président doit être élu sans plus
de délai et enfin nous relayons
l'aspiration du peuple libanais à la
justice alors vous mentionnez le
déplacement de juge d'instructions
français il s'agit d'une affaire
judiciaire en cours et donc il ne
m'appartient pas
il a commenté deuxièmement s'agissant de
l'enquête relative à l'explosion
survenue sur le port de Beyrouth le 4
août 2020 c'est une procédure distincte
il est essentiel en effet que toute la
lumière soit faite sur cette explosion
qui a frappé le port mais qui a fait de
très nombreuses victimes vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le sénateur et sur ce
point vous le savez le Liban a fait le
choix d'une enquête nationale c'est son
choix souverain la France reste
disponible et le Liban on le sait pour
apporter toute l'aide qui serait
nécessaire alors oui l'enquête est
aujourd'hui bloquée il faut redire que
les victimes ont droit à la vérité
qu'elles ont besoin de vérité cette
enquête doit reprendre elle doit
reprendre son délai et elle doit être
conduite naturellement en toute
transparence et en toute indépendance
pour être plus précise elle doit être
conduite à l'abri de toute interférence
politique donc la justice doit être
rendue le responsable do rendre des
comptes et c'est donc bien volontiers
monsieur le sénateur que je réponds
ainsi à votre appel merci
monsieur Cadic
merci madame la ministre et vous le
savez pour beaucoup pour beaucoup aucune
solution politique économique ou
sécurité n'envisageable au Liban tant
que l'occupation iranienne du Hezbollah
durera nous devons appuyer toutes les
initiatives qui visent à rétréblir la
neutralité du Liban 80% des Libanais
vivent sous le seuil de la pauvreté ne
les oublions pas merci
si nous en avons terminé merci madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 25
janvier à 15h
j'informe le Sénat que des candidatures
pour sier au sein de la commission mixte
paritaire chargé d'élaborer un texte sur
les dispositions restantes en discussion
du projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production de
l'énergie renouvelable que c'est
l'historiques
seront ratifiées si la présidence n'a
pas reçu d'opposition dans le délai
d'une heure prévue par notre règlement
la séance s'est levée elle reprendra le
mardi 24 janvier à 9h30 pour les
questions orales la science est levée